amidst the devastation caused by these
fires communities across oregon are
stepping up to help each other
arcade houston is live now at the
clackamas county fairgrounds where
donations have been coming in all week
kate
yes hi sasha i'm inside one of these
donation rooms and right now volunteers
are going through and sorting
all of these items here for the evacuees
and the animals that they've brought to
the fairgrounds as you can see
they have lots of food here for people
who need it lots of pallets of water
definitely needed during
these wildfires with all of that smoke
and it looks like they're even setting
up
another table over here for more
donations and to the side
you know it's actually getting pretty
cold here at night so there have
blankets they have some cot set up for
those evacuees now about three dozen
people are staying here right now some
in their cars and trailers
more than 700 animals have been
evacuated here and i'm told that there
are more on the way
and in addition to the donations here
other businesses in camby are
offering help including pappy's greasy
spoon
owner michael merrill opened up the
restaurant today to help feed displaced
people and those helping fight these
fires
my heart goes out to them i helped out a
little bit cash wise for what i could do
if i was a rich man i'd feed everybody
for nothing but it's been a long year
with all the bologna this year but
we'll we'll keep on trucking oh it feels
real good it really feels good this is
where our community comes together the
most
so when we get into a time of crisis
like this everybody comes together
everybody helps everybody
staff at the fairgrounds tells me many
companies such as winco and coastal farm
and ranch have stepped up to make sure
everyone here is fed the sheriff's
office is also here
assisting with the intake of all of
those animals now back here in the
donation room they do still need some
help all of these donations that are
coming in
they are going out very quickly to those
who need assistance
they're asking for sleeping bags
blankets warm clothing
and tents because like i said it is
getting a little chilly outside which is
good news for those firefighters
reporting live from the clackamas county
fairgrounds kate houston 8 news now
so kate i know a lot of people are
evacuating and bringing those
go bags with them so the question i
guess is exactly what should people
bring if they do have to evacuate
yeah that's a great question a go bag is
essential if you are evacuating and if
you have time to prepare so
basically they say you should have a
week's worth of clothing and hygiene
products
important documents and some medication
and if you have time you can also grab
some of those irreplaceable items
and the red cross has a very
comprehensive list on their website as
well